hello and welcome to a very special
episode of wild ride with steve-o not
only is Whitney Cummings just an
incredible talent and a huge star this
episode is special because I really went
into it feeling like I needed to open up
to get personal you know and more
importantly I wanted to really really be
mindful about trying to do a better job
so I think this is a very personal
episode plus our very own young [ __ ]
tells a super personal story which he
hasn't never shared publicly so yeah
enjoy ladies and gentlemen you guys
think I have covered an abundance of
caution
seriously but it's exciting because we
haven't had a guest in the van I mean
dude since who we've only had two
rhonda / zoom and the zooms have been so
hard I feel like comedians we work so
tirelessly on developing good comic
timing and then you get on zoom' and
there's like a two second delay yeah
have you done any comedy bit at the
comedy shows on Zoom no I don't hate
myself that much and then people can
record record you and comedy is the
whole point of comedies that's in front
of straight live strangers in the room
right now you have agents I presume that
have been trying just racking their
brain trying to figure out how to sell
tickets what did you hang from an
airplane and fly over a town you know
yeah everyone's trying to get super
creative about it and I just I think
that it's kind of interesting that the
job we chose involves people sitting
shoulder to shoulder and X
hailing for about an hour and then also
taking drinks from a stranger in the
dark to put up to their mouths and the
whole like but they're gonna be in face
masks like we also rely on that sound
right uh if we go I will quit comedy if
I tour around America and hear like
muffled laughs I'll just think I'm
bombing my brain can't override but
their word mask and then Bert's doing a
drive drive in comedy comedians and cars
with comedy yeah
drive drive nice the nights summer
nights is what it's called yeah in a
laugh as a honk like you like light taps
if it's like yeah standing oh just so I
can hear the laughter they're trying to
do a lot of outdoor comedy which never
worked pre kovat it's a lot of that like
during the day comedy under a tent
um I'll wait a couple months right I'll
just stay home write more stuff wait a
couple months engage with the fans were
I mean we're very lucky that we record
podcasts for sure it we're new to it
we're new to it and it's all soon I know
we were kind of born to do it like you
just have that skill right but it's also
a lot of work oh my god you know I think
if we were doing stand-up right now the
at least my podcast would be very sloppy
and kind of well here's how I view it
and I've been thinking about it a lot
because like particularly recently I've
just felt all of a sudden overwhelmed
with anxiety stress over the getting of
guests yep it's like you know and it it
just it just landed on me like a ton of
bricks like in the last week like the
fear of asking right I don't like
[ __ ] asking I feel like vermin permit
like I feel like a rapist right
it does feel that way yeah because for
me it's like the most annoying question
somebody just say hey I'm famous I'm
gonna get you more followers and more
views and make people like you more
there's that that's what you're actually
asking right you know and I think it
takes a long time for people to catch up
with how successful they are and we
never view ourselves the way other
people view us it's just crazy
I'm always shocked when someone says yes
first of all shock and then coming up
until the day I'm like are you sure are
you sure dad maybe you thought it was
someone out like are you sure you want
to you don't have to come I can come to
you see me like 10 minutes max I'll
donate all my proceeds do you have a
charity like I can't it's the hardest
thing for me is to accept a yes when I
do get the nerve up to ask I ask
personally you ask personally it's
interesting and I was talking to someone
about it recently about you know I'm
into 12-step program I'm in coda and
like I have put myself in a situation
where every week I have to do my worst
nightmare which is ask someone for help
or to do something for me and it's still
so hard and even sometimes when I'm in
an interview I'm like I'm going too long
I'm pushing it they don't want to be
here they're miserable they're having a
great time I love the the fact that we
are so distorted in our thinking that we
think in Hollywood people don't want to
talk about themselves for two hours
right all they want it's all they want
and I like to think that however it's
still just it's still just a [ __ ]
nightmare you need to like yourself as
much as we all like you nice I mean
that's not my go-to I felt like it's a
very true thing oh thank you it's it's
what what happened when you asked Demi
Lovato that was a little bit uh I took
some time to put together there was you
know like a response right away like oh
yeah I'll do it but then there was just
like with the schedule I think that's
what bums you out the
is like managing that like in case
something gets bad like [ __ ] I love
doing that [ __ ] it's a little bit like
you're at them it's a lot like you're at
the mercy of somebody else yeah you know
like I have a pretty good work ethic and
in sort of Scott like God does Scott
ever and it's like we just hammer like
we would just get things done and then
now there's this this you know extra
layer which we can't control and you
know what and I think that it took me a
while to learn this and I remember
podcasting not much longer than you I
will shoot like three in a week so that
if the next person cancels I have one
already shot ready to go and sometimes
I'll just do like an open to make it
feel fresh you know right because I
think I was so for assuming everyone
would always cancel or reschedule
right and and I wish that we would do a
better job of getting out in front and
banking them but with what's going on
right like right now I'm kind of scared
to bank out too far because the world's
gonna explode
yeah it's gonna actually explode right
nowa meteor is murder were somehow the
best news of 2020 I remember just like
opening my laptop CNN which I won't even
go to anymore at this point but it was
just like meteor flying within two and
it was just like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you at
this point they should just cancel 2020
and like we should just take the rest of
your someone said the dumbest thing I
bought for 2020 is an event planner and
you know but this is like honestly I do
feel like I know everyone's new thing
I'm so la but like the universe is
serving you in such a way because no
one's able to really do anything except
exactly the thing you created which is a
you know van that comes to your house
and you're six feet away and you get to
vent out what's going on with you you
know like I feel like it took the
pandemic for me to ask a couple people
because I was like oh I can't ask them
when things are up and things are busy
but now they have nothing to do and I'm
doing them a favor so they can get out
of their house and away from their weird
marriage or whatever right I mean we
switched it up pretty good dude I mean I
just I just
ambitious I thought you know I hear I'm
Jeff jumped on the podcast bandwagon
let me just blow people away with like
oh my god I can't believe steve-o got
Danny Lovato
Yeah right wild I can't believe steve-o
got Shaq you know and I just was
convinced in my mind if I got enough
like really impressive guests huh I
would hit a tipping point and all of a
sudden the floodgates are open yeah yeah
yeah but then it felt like oh wait a
second the tipping point is and it
doesn't seem to be happening and it's
actually gonna be noted that people go
yeah Demi Lovato he's fine Yeah right so
I just actually like was sending like
you know and like really frustrated like
but her texts to my podcast team saying
hey guys look if it's gonna be up to me
to do all of the booking like I'm just
telling you like I don't know how much
longer I can do it yeah really it's
really making me stressed out and and
unhappy so what about let's hire a
Booker oh did you do that I am looking
into it I am gonna just tell me to shut
up at any time or not I don't I actually
have to work on [ __ ] shutting up
myself
I disagree I think that you talking is
quite a [ __ ] gift
I learned something every time I talk to
you and the feedback I got I sent you
some of them because I would get carpal
tunnel if I screen grabbed all of them
the feedback I got when you were on my
podcast men were texting me like this
made me want to go to a 12-step program
this made me want to step up for my wife
in the quote it still gives me chills
I'm gonna be the man that my girl
deserves yep I did I'm doing the work to
become the man that love of my life
deserves I mean I'm sure you broke a
couple people up because a lot of women
really know I'm gonna wait for the man
who's sure it's [ __ ] up a couple
relationships but I mean I think that we
have to remember in this podcast thing
is someone who is deeply cripplingly
insecure and to find myself through my
relationships with others of like you
like me I must be good right now you
don't like me I must be bad so I think
it took me a while and
to realize like I don't need giant
celebrities on my podcast
you know like Who am I gonna have the
best chemistry with who do I genuinely
hate wanna hang out with and I think
that's what you know Rogan and burn all
these pits what they do so well is they
just surround themselves with their
friends a little bit you know none of
those guys really had celebrities on for
a while right can I tell you that I'm
honored to have you as a friend
lucky I mean it's what you were
describing earlier like no really like
you can back out anytime like I'm just
sitting here like man Whitney Cummings
it's like like I said on your podcast
how when we really met officially for
the first time coming out of the comedy
store yeah you're so warm to me and that
man
oh yeah the improv exactly I remember it
and I just remember thinking like wow
like because I've had in the comedy
world of stand-up comedians it's like
sort of self-consciousness this
insecurity nobody wants to view steve-o
as a stand-up comedian but like you
really being warm to me in it and and I
said you know meeting up and going to
your show and in Vancouver your show too
because I saw it I saw I think like the
second or third performance before you
actually take that's right sorry I
didn't even like watch this because I'd
seen it you had seen it verbatim yeah
and it was - the robot of robot came out
of presence and there's that disastrous
meeting with I think most people are
aware that and if they're not with
Whitney for her last comedy special for
Netflix which is so unbelievably I told
you it's a home run
you can I tell you I don't I think it is
so important and it's taken me a long
time to realize who my tribe is you know
who my sort of go-to people are that I
can trust and how to make new old
friends you know I think when you click
with somebody when you trust someone
just like gopher because I have spent my
whole life trying to make bad
relationships work and try to make
narcissists love me and try to make
alcoholics get sober with my love and
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can meet someone right away and feel
like you were family period and we just
met and it was like that and there was
no weirdness and there was no like oh
you have a girlfriend can I not text you
it was just like straight up like the
way you live your life is so clean and
your motives are so pure that it was
just I think we had this thing right
away but when I was doing that I knew
you just enough to have the gut instinct
that I could trust you but not at all
enough to where I felt like you were
kissing your ass yes yes and you didn't
know how insecure I was and how I'm
hanging by a thread so I knew you
weren't saying it because you know that
I would have jumped off a building had
you said anything else but you said
you're like you're sitting on a bomb and
that totally drove me into my special
confidence let me qualify that statement
- I have so much difficulty sitting
through an hour of stand-up comedy like
it's just so divided like I lost respect
for you for being there frankly I don't
even watch of course like there's the
ship l1 yeah [ __ ] sticks and stones
blow my mind they're so good yeah but I
just find that the majority of stand-up
comedy is just really [ __ ] mediocre
and when I was at your show I'd never
felt the urge to look at my phone once
I'd like was I tend to make things
flaccid it's my person being such a
stereotype of a woman but like I think
that you know for you podcasting is so
yes thank you
I don't man help you milena video a
millennial on the arm Paul tighten up
that little [ __ ] screw yeah these are
my OC white
3000 oh my god can't tell you it's a
tacky look see how it's attacking me
that that scar comes with like three
others
see ya okay this is this is Paul I love
a guy who's so handsome that he can have
that shitty a mustache that feels good
[Laughter]
Paul is gorgeous he's my editor and
great stuff we were in Peru where I
found Wendy okay it was this this
YouTube [ __ ] reality show oh yeah
I've seen the YouTube of when you got
her yeah with Chuck Liddell and a bunch
of youtubers and stuff and we all it was
like mountain climbing with the Stars so
crazy experience it was kind of whatever
but Paul was the the digital department
head right whatever that means and I
promise this is gonna get really juicy
right now because on the last night the
wrap party they all went out to like
some Club I showed up at the wrap party
play I'm a sober guy I was there for
like a half an hour
okay guys about it then the next day
we're all heading to the airport is
worse Paul there's like I wonder where
Paul is and and I didn't even occur to
me I didn't even know I didn't even find
out until like a couple weeks later but
nobody could find Paul and around and
then the guide to the point of let's
call hospitals let's call jail as it's
called you know the whole thing nobody
could find Paul and then somebody just
had the thought to go to the nightclub
that they were all at the night before
and and actually go on the roof Club and
then look down from the roof oh my god
there was again there was a [ __ ]
construction site like all fenced round
so you would never been able to see it
from the ground you could only see from
the roof that Paul fell off the [ __ ]
roof over this three-story building
landed in a pile of rubble okay and
was stuck there unable to move with a
completely collapsed lung like a
shattered like arm yeah it was bad well
first of all as a four-story building I
really don't think a more tragic messed
up story has ever been funnier but just
wait Paul's gonna reveal how shockingly
serious his injuries were and we're all
gonna laugh our butts off about it but
before that I want to tell you about
what's on my right wrist right here you
might have noticed me wearing this for
the last good month or two it's called a
whoop strap it's a fitness tracker and
I'm telling you right now I have no
plans of taking it off ever and I don't
have to take it off ever because the
charger which I keep in my pocket at all
times
slides right on it's right there that's
charging and this thing gives me
insights into my health and fitness that
are unbelievable it knows when I lay
down it knows when I fall asleep it
knows how much REM sleep I got how much
deep sleep I got it knows when I
exercise it can actually tell me when I
just got on my bicycle and cycled you
know I like it's got me skateboarding
again because right within the app I'm
skateboarding you know and I'm just
getting more exercise than ever I'm
understanding my sleep how many
disturbances I have how much my body's
recovered it's telling me what I need to
do to optimize my fitness my health my
day I mean dude I want everybody to try
this so if you go to woop calm that is
WH o o P calm and use the promo code
steve-o you're gonna get 15 percent off
at checkout and it is so worth it
I really feel like I'm on the verge of
being healthier at 46 years old then
I've ever been in my life and it's got a
lot to do with this thing man with the
strain coach the sleep coach this it's
really incredible so try it again
whoop calm use the promo code steve-o
you get 15% off at checkout you're gonna
be so glad you did it and yeah I just
woke up on the ground I don't remember
you being on the roof did you think you
were gonna die yeah no no to be honest I
never thought like oh I probably woke up
at like 9 a.m. or something and they
feel like 3:30 in the afternoon my phone
was dead my walkie-talkie was dead my
burner phone so yeah I try to drink my
own pee I was just so thirsty and hot it
was rough so I broke my my femur my
humerus I shattered my wrist Jesus I
broke six ribs in nine places I sure are
we're falling
I don't remember falling thank God I
punctured both my lungs but only one of
them collapsed
does that happen when a rib goes into I
don't know and then I hit my head super
hard and I had frostbite were you drunk
I think you were hot well well because
it's really cold that night but it's hot
in the day it's like a like a desert
climate sort of a thing so at night I
had this big winter jacket that like
production gave me to work on this
mountain climbing show but then I fell
wearing that jacket it saved a lot of
maybe it did it was puffy but I woke up
in the day and I'm stuck in this jacket
and I can't even get it off so I'm just
like baking in the Sun and this big
black like yeah what happens when your
lung collapses like is it was it hard to
breathe or you didn't notice until
[ __ ] they told hi I mean I think I
Frank I knew the ribs my ribs were
broken
I couldn't tell that my lung was
collapsed and they didn't find him until
like 3:30 in the afternoon and he had
all that [ __ ] broke and he was laying
pile of rubble and then when they came
up to him and actually found him he said
can I have some water I was yeah I was
very thirsty you feel pain in the wrist
you shattered I felt the pain everywhere
yeah I mean it's all everything
everything hurt but I kind of woke up
with the baby crying no I don't I didn't
cry was just a lot of like were there
any points where you were like all day
yeah no there's no footage of it nah
there's nothing there's no footage like
that there's an there's news footage
because they put out like it was a
search party so the news caught on that
that someone was missing so when they
actually found me and the police and the
ambulance showed up there's also these
news cameras so there is a news story
that like played locally where you can
see me getting pulled out on a stretcher
that's a good question no no I was out
there by myself by myself dude
no there was there were lots of theories
because they were like prostitutes at
the bar that night so that everyone
thought like maybe something happened
with these prostitutes and like someone
tried to kill me or something but I
think I just went up to the roof and
tried to like pee off of it or something
like I was kind of soaking up some
moment I don't know I wish I knew I like
I would know I'm telling we solved it
yeah maybe I survived murder every day I
don't know I just I I don't know but to
be honest there was never a moment where
I was like I'm gonna die I never feared
I was like they're gonna find me they'll
figure it out it's a giant production
team it's like you know I figured they
just they had to find me
I [ __ ] died like
minute four because I'd be tripping
myself out so hard in the head I'd been
called to for me because I've got to cut
it off at our [ __ ] two so yeah that's
paws scarf however you this was I was 27
have you do you have a history of peeing
off roofs yeah kind of like if I'm on it
nightmare fighting with you you're that
guy who's like I didn't say no no I'm
not [ __ ] no no no no I'm easy yeah yes
I totally know I just I don't know guys
just like to pee office tell you to know
me define sheet how dare you accuse me
of when you ask a guy like hey where
were you till 2:00 a.m.
where was I told to am like they're
trying to come up with an answer yeah
yeah as they're repeating your questions
you what did why you have to repeat my
question
yeah I think a PSA guy said that most
people can't remember lies three stories
in yeah yes because they only think
about it you know like the first two
well I fell for stores dude
just in its give me the respect of
coming up with your lie on the way home
like yeah this lipstick yeah I bumped
into a girl when I was a girl named I'm
now at the point where I'm so honest
that I I'm so polite I'm rude okay you
know I mean I feel like I'm this
pendulums going too far in the other
direction because I've been such a lying
piece of so polite you're rude or so
honest I really there's a so I I guess I
think they're synonymous my whole thing
is like I never you know we're only as
sick as the secrets we keep right and I
never want to lie to anyone so I'll just
go out of my way to be like hey I know I
laugh to that joke but I don't like it
right you're allowed to say nothing also
that's not polite no
yeah so honest
you're rude yeah I'm the same way yeah I
like that though I've value that in
people yeah at least you can trust them
that they're being genuine you know I'll
take a genuine [ __ ] over a fake kind
person any day
tweet it because as you know when and
not because of anything that you've ever
done but I've shared with you what I've
been like man I'd someone didn't get
back to me and I feel like it's like
what the [ __ ] like just gonna just go
radio silent like that's such a [ __ ]
move yeah and and then every time when
it comes up in somebody like reaches out
to me and I don't want to respond or I
don't like I don't want to do what
they're asking me to do I always think
of it and I'm like you know what I'm
gonna get right back to them and I'm
gonna say no yes it's good and also I
think we have to remember that like you
know especially in you booking this
podcast since this is gonna go on for
awhile like most people in my experience
in our business is a little dicey but
like if they want to say no they'll just
say no I can't do that I'm projecting my
[ __ ] on that right and then I lied for
so long and did things that I didn't
want to do out of obligation and
pressure that when someone says yes to
me I think they're doing it codependent
and I don't trust that
well what instead of saying no you come
up with like a paragraph instead of like
a sentence hey I have a dry cough I
don't know I should probably take the
two I mean anything except except this
past weekend when I didn't write you
back this is actually real so I'm in
al-anon
I can drink I don't like to drink it's
just not for me I'm not good at it like
it makes me sick gives me headaches but
anyway I was doing this sponsored kind
of Spawn con cuz look I don't know when
touring is coming back so I had a like a
shot of that I had to shoot for
something a shot of peanut butter with
spunk on what's common sponsor sentence
Oh gotcha
you know like though and that's the age
yes I do I've never had a representative
that got me any [ __ ] sponsored condo
spot the number
and the number of threats and mental
manipulation I have to do you know I
think the way that I did in the
beginning was and I I never do I think
this actually would be an interesting
conversation for your fans I never do
any sponsored content unless it's
something that I actually I say no a lot
of [ __ ] I think audiences are too smart
now if I can make it funny completely my
own words be able to say like I can't
believe they paid me for this I've no
[ __ ] idea if I can't say all that I
won't do it but I started just to
Instagram storing a couple products that
I just like if I would just like hey yo
this ultimate [ __ ] mic stand
I just put my podcast that's awesome
look at it I'll just whatever make it
with no money right and then I think
then brands start going oh he'd be open
to this oh we should talk to me and then
I just started [ __ ] calling brands
out in my show I was doing some makeup
tutorial thing and I was like Revlon
where's my contract [ __ ] right and then
they call me Wow you know so I think um
you know you have to like manifest it
ask for it feel that you deserve it you
know you've got a huge following well
maybe they just don't know my and and of
course that like the podcast my podcast
guy is great at finding sponsors for the
show and i'm the same way i only agree
to things that uh that i both use and
that i really like yeah like I did this
vegan I'm obsessed with that Kali Power
vegan pizza and I was already just
showing it all the time being like it's
made of [ __ ] cauliflower escritt and
then they just reached out to me and
like would you want to do an IG live and
like yeah I'd be doing it anyway [ __ ]
yeah that's great you know I bet we
definitely got sidetracked off your
special and your robot for the people
who don't know you have this
fan-fucking-tastic special on Netflix
it's called can I touch it
and before it was genius on your part
because not only as the stand-up just
genius and your first joke this is
special if I recall you know I've been
taking some time just working on writing
you know like I was writing Roseanne's
tweets I put in special yes you saw me
do it
it was just
like I don't need I did I love that that
we just gave them something that they
didn't know about I know I think that's
right you just got exclusive content
dude that was such a huge joke because
everybody knows that Roseann lost
everything over a tweet now it's a good
rabbit writing tweet I just [ __ ]
hilarious see it's so doing stand-up is
so hard because I think there sometimes
you have to give up jokes that [ __ ]
kill that dude I love that that was your
first joke and it was just the whole
place whoa and now we're on for this
ride yeah and as jeans and then oh my
god like the marquee joke of it's like
here we are in the me to movement
I understand how guys feel in the me to
movement it's me when I see a but it
works cuz i I've never had a service dog
with a vest on I respect it you know
this I don't remember verbatim the joke
but that's then that's what women need
at work we need little nurse a lady
working it's so good and I think now
making it special for people that are
obviously if you're a comedy fan if
you're listening to this like they're
kind of saying people only watch the
first 10 minutes your first 10 minutes
get has to be cracking now you know so
it's got to be like I would normally put
a joke like that as my closer and I was
like I'm so insecure and so obsessed
with keeping the audience's attention
since there are so many choices now and
people can so easily go I'll just finish
that later you know right you have to
keep them addicted to whatever you're
watching so I've moved that up top and
then I put a robot at the end really cuz
I was like if people didn't finish it
and said I'll just finish this later
they'd be at a party in some did you see
what happened at the end right and maybe
ghost genius and you let the cat out of
the bag personally letting me know that
your retention for your special yes yeah
yeah I just was like we have got to
adapt you know this whole thing we're
comedians are like I want to be able to
say the n-word like in the amount of
time you've been complaining about this
you could have written some new jokes
you know like why can't I do this joke
good this is just right new jokes just
adapt just a
off you know it's on us to do that but
yeah I think that having a genius hour
of stand-up it's just not enough anymore
you know that's like I mean maybe it is
you were so clever by having this this
Robin tying it all into the whole like
me to moment and it's like here I've got
this this robot the sex doll this this
fantastic thing and you know it's just
it was just a great gimmick and titles
are always weird I wanted somebody
everybody said to me they were like
Netflix never gives you notes on
anything they never tell you can do
whatever title you want I like a lot of
these other networks that micromanage
you and hose wait oh my god that's
amazing I wanted to call it bear claw
cuz that was the name of the robot and I
was like just bear claw with a rut like
I'm watching that I loved Chris Rock's
tambourine I thought that was just I was
like I want to know what that joke is
you know and I sent it to Netflix never
like they told me this the titles that
drove eyeballs and watch and help me
understand why and so I decided to call
it can I touch it because when I have
the robot with me everyone's like oh
right let's say that that epic service
dog joke can I touch it and then I
thought it was interesting that no one
ever asked me if they can touch me but
then when the robot ever was like I said
the genius of the robot goes even beyond
the special because it was such a
promotional tool I mean you were on a
press tour and talking about the [ __ ]
robot and yeah the robot actually like
you can program it to talk move the
initial expression that's laughs like
the whole thing it's like you know
cutting-edge technology like [ __ ]
artificial intelligence like robot and
and so you went around and you got like
a bunch of your friends to film promos
for like social media and stuff to drive
traffic to the special which was just
completely genius I love you have
inspired me a lot like that not only
your work ethic but the way you're able
to create these holy [ __ ] moments like
that they
things that matter right now I think in
terms of getting people to give a [ __ ]
about what you're doing I think comedy
is like there's so much about there's so
many specials to watch there's so many I
think being able to really shock someone
really surprise someone or touch their
heart Molnar ability which is why I
think this is essential because you have
such an incredible heart and brain and
people don't get to see that like this
is like gonna make people that like
we're like oh steve-o's are down this
weekend should we go to steve-o's in
town we have to get tickets right this
second I think that's the difference I
appreciate it but everybody you know
what I'm getting at is that when you
brought your robot over to room with me
at my house right here I'm sitting here
like okay you know Whitney Cummings is
coming over to like to get me to shoot
like a promo for her special like oh
[ __ ] I gotta be I gotta be funny and I
was like just so like what am I gonna do
and I didn't have a plan I just was so I
sit down with this [ __ ] robot neither
did I by the way I sit down with the
robot and like yeah just riff it's all
good and like just out of my mouth comes
like so what are the chances me [ __ ]
why did I say that
how did that just come out of just like
trying too hard I was like it's so funny
because I could feel it and I it's this
is how insecure I am I was just like he
doesn't want to be here I shouldn't have
asked him no I wanted to so much but I
just wanted to be funny yeah what what
time do you go to bed that night because
you're spinning out so hard on that
comment oh my god I'm just thinking like
how [ __ ] disrespectful of my girl but
I wished and then I blame myself when
you first told me about this house like
god I wish I had given off the vibe that
he felt comfortable going hey do you
mind cutting that I mean I probably
could have but I just didn't want like I
don't like to censor myself that kind
it's so funny because you're doing
you're thinking that he's thinking that
we're just all [ __ ] thinking that
that's so funny like
it is you know so interesting because
you know people that listen a comedy
podcast I think they really appreciate
it when comedians say stuff like this
which is like I have wasted so much time
I have [ __ ] up so many relationships I
have just been embarrassed myself so
much just being desperate to be funny
and then just being consumed with shame
afterwards oh my god I was so ashamed
and I just felt it was so disrespectful
of my girl and it was just you know it
corrodes our esteem you know but then
but then you know all this time later of
course he of course that was the promo
because that was like the moment like it
was the most like and then I'm like I
can't you know obviously was hilarious
if I cut it he's gonna see that I cut
his right right and so it's just it's
all crazy mayhem it comes out my girls
like wow so I saw that and I was like
bad so I'm so [ __ ] sorry I said that
I just was trying so hard and she was
she just appreciated she was like a she
was like hey thank you for being honest
you know I thought it sucked and it
means something to me that you would
acknowledge that that sucked and and to
then there's you know why you did it
right you know most people don't do that
because like I think you're rare in a
sense we're like you doesn't have work
on yourself where you can explain it
like the average guy is gonna be like
what the [ __ ] like get defensive and
then react and then it's an argument I
mean it's called comedy that's for a
long time I've been [ __ ] comedian I
have to be able to talk about everything
I could you know I just go on stage and
talk about all the dicks I sucked or
whatever and then my dudes in the back
just like mmm you know in comedy get out
get stronger it's like yeah it was never
an issue and interestingly like once I
saw your doing in the podcast I'm doing
the podcast and I was just like man I
wonder like what what Whitney's YouTube
channels like you know like the podcast
is she is she I don't even look at it as
she putting up do you have one pod can
one youtube channel I think so and and
the podcast goes up as well as like you
know whatever content oh I do the
podcast comes out Wednesdays just audio
say it then comes out on you too I just
and I don't mean I'm not complaining I'm
very grateful
I think anyone that takes the time to
make a comment even if it's negative you
love me you love me
it took the time to make a comment about
how much you hate me and you love me
right
so I'm now at this place where I'm like
not you know but I think the YouTube
comments are ten yuen yuen ly
predominantly male and I get a lot of
like you're busted you know what's on
your face even your demographics are
all-male I I think YouTube in general is
more male uh but there's a thumbs down
button which I just don't like I just so
weird I don't know why that needs to be
there do you have a contact that I can
consent I'll reach out yeah thanks yeah
I really I think I just get I just avoid
looking at YouTube comments cuz I don't
or the thumbs down I was terrified to
look at any comments absolutely
terrified and I didn't thank God but
what I did notice was that on your
YouTube channel the little video of me
asking to [ __ ] your robot you know I
mean is cringy and awful and that's
probably why I had attracted so many
views I the numbers are way too
impressive to do that I can't even
remember what it is but it was like high
in the ranks
[Laughter]
watching it over and over he felt so
much Jamie after saying it until he saw
the views not I should you should get
the right the YouTube revenue off of
that you really which I never checked by
the way I don't even know if that
happens there that there it's it's a
crazy deal the YouTube revenue situation
yeah I mean I which brings me to a
question is dying to ask you okay man
I've actually got some questions and so
like we've been just you know letting
the time get away from us but this is
what I was told podcasts are right I'm
telling you you have a heart like just
been a great conversation it has we're
such perfectionist were okay we need to
get to like more quiet everyone's like
we're enjoying this zero questions yeah
it's like they get to hear people
interviewed all the time they want to
just hear us shoot the [ __ ] yeah okay
but yes there's enough like I know
better than to ever ask like financial
like without putting actual numbers on
because that's just a little bit yeah
not classy I just yelled I'm Brit
shipping trailer yeah what has been the
predominant revenue stream because your
on-camera talent yeah you're onstage
stand-up comedian right you're like
off-camera producer and your off-camera
writer mmm-hmm so is it as a writer as a
producer as a on-camera talent or as a
stand-up comedian which of these revenue
streams mm-hmm and have they taken turns
being in the number one I'm so rich I
have no [ __ ] idea that's how rich I am
I'm just Wayne ass when I could buy this
man from you know I am gonna be very
clear I make that joke because I am
consumed a shame about money I'm
consumed with fear about it I think
there I did go through a little bit of a
thing where there was an announcement of
how much money I was making from a show
I created a new show the tubercles oh
wow and if the projection was like 40
million dollars in syndication that's
not what it ended up being like I just
AM like always feel like people see me
as like super financially successful and
it's just weird people make jokes about
it I just I just have shame around it I
grew up in an environment where we did
not have money but we pretended we have
had money and it was all about like
keeping up with the Joneses and stuff
and getting the latest sneakers but not
paying the heating bill and my mom
having the nicest you know Chanel shoes
but we didn't have food in the
refrigerator so it's like I just had a
big like I have a lot of shame around
money I will also tell you the biggest
ways I've lost money is both my parents
had strokes without health insurance so
I lost a lot to the ICU and to paying
for siblings rehab for a couple years so
I should have more what I'm saying to
the shame around money mm-hmm and and
and for me it's it's a little bit the
opposite because I grew up with a super
successful father around country to
country born in England six months old
moved to Brazil because dad was the
president of all of Pepsi Cola in all of
Brazil whoa by the way can I say
something really quick I was an argument
the other day with a guy I'm sleeping
with I'm a Pepsi person I'm not a coke
person I said it at a restaurant do you
go India Pepsi or coke products and you
get pissed if they only have pay usually
people will go ask for a coke and
they'll go we only have Pepsi but yes
I'm shocked that you would even drink a
soda in bin white trash what are you
talking about I do do diet or regular I
just go for the regular I had such about
eating disorders for so long that it's
like I can't get in that slippery slope
okay you know so I'll just do if I do
one coke once a week that will satiate
me so I up stood nine diet cokes a day
good I bless the diet makes you fatter
anyway that's right and just
like bloated and you're not hydrating
yourself and whatever some minor thing
is I eat the thing that's full fat full
calorie whatever satiate myself my inner
child feels fed and then I don't do the
nasty half whatever that's part of what
is it aspartame aspartame he had surgery
right my dirty little secret is I I only
drink soda water coffee or regular water
but I'll drink a coca-cola from the
country I'm in so if I'm in a different
country I'll do that what a treat I
heard there's like there's like 27
different styles of coca-cola based off
the country because some have only cane
sugar some have only this type of
product or whatever okay if I just have
like I've gotten to the point with my
eating stuff where if I just kind of
don't restrict myself or deprive myself
I don't get into that shame addiction
and that need for the pendulum to swing
so hard so if I'll just have like a
ice-cold Pepsi and just then I won't eat
like 9 cookies at 2:00 a.m. I read a
comment on YouTube yesterday I said god
I love Scott but stop eating those
[ __ ] cakes that's like the only one I
saw and I was just like bro cakes also
means but maybe that's and then
yesterday is two in one day some girl
just said something like I was I was
talking to her on text messages she's
like dad pods and gray hair or in she's
like you must be killing it in 2020 is a
girl this party with you we're just like
having a conversation my dad was never
around I don't know dad looks like it
looks like this there it is I think
you're very hot yeah yes you are
thank you I appreciate that where you
from Pasadena nice nice
where are you oh you're from these
coasts you see in Virginia yes sir
I know you you were on the middle of a
questionnaire so for me you know I
created a show that was syndicated which
is really as of two years ago was kind
of the only way to make money in
television when you have points on the
back end right like a Will and Grace
Chuck Laurie's show you know two and a
half
mom Big Bang Theory all those they have
to go about eighty eight episodes
normally in order to get syndicated
which means another network buys them so
everyone listening you how you see
Seinfeld on TBS and you see right on CMT
they pay a bunch of money to buy the
whole show and that's when you get your
points cashed in and the points of the
value of the show depends on how the
ratings of the show depends on how
valuable the points are right so friends
points were notoriously the most
lucrative may watch Baywatch I've you
know comedies tend to syndicate better
but in the Baywatch day I'm sure was
massive I think Baywatch was notoriously
the biggest most valuable that makes a
lot of sense self and Michael Patrick
King created it and what does that mean
producer right
you create it so you get basically most
of the back end and then you're an EP in
series and a writer in series but
creator is where you get the point so I
created the NBC show I did Co Whitney
but we only went like 50 episodes or
something you need to go 88 to really
cash in and syndication and then stay
touring and stand-up I do well my
specials I do well but I end up putting
so much of my fee into the production
that I don't keeping a lot of the money
what the robot cost when we shot at
about 75 grand now about a hundred grand
ok and stuff I brought her question okay
I know she's she actually you guys
probably have a lot of the same injuries
I brought in a Jimmy Kimmel and she fell
off of a desk and her old face came off
so we had to get her new eyeballs I just
had to get new eyebrows put in because
they're now doing hair on the eyebrows
and they're soon gonna make it so the
eyes can be camera so they can actually
the robot can address people they can
recognize you and go hey Steve oh hey
looks good to see you that's so cool
when you keep it in my house and you
don't freak out at night in the dark and
you're walking by and
I just go how many times she's off most
of the time yeah right yeah you ever
seen like a thriller movie like that
[ __ ] can I tell you I fear II that men
are more afraid of robots than women I
realize this very gender because it's
you guys are like nothing else is really
trying to kill you and I feel like
robots are the first thing that might be
stronger than you smarter than you and
might be out to kill you like women were
like used to people trying to kill us
all time yeah yeah there is something
called pathogen avoidance you know when
guys get like grossed out when they said
boo you know like weirded out
it's how we evolved essentially to
recoil when we see something that looks
human but also doesn't move like a human
that looks sick or dead it's our sort of
evolutionary way to not [ __ ] something a
corpse or like a Chucky doll like that
would freak me the [ __ ] out thing at
night by myself a big this is out of
here this feels like a conversation for
your therapist I look I the robot we
looked the same age like a year ago now
I look about 40 years older I don't know
if it's covert or stress or I don't know
I think because you're dating now I
think that you'd like I think you look
fantastic and I get in trouble with when
we showed up today I've seen their clips
on Instagram I think man you know
Whitney's really thank you well I do
have four Giants floodlights in my
podcast I don't know what this situation
is I'm already worried about it but yeah
I started taking better care of myself I
started doing the NAD drips and peptide
injections nad is like extends longevity
of your telomeres Wow
is that right something like that right
it sounded right it basically what it
does is it the ATP in your cells
transfers some [ __ ] to sometimes oh
[ __ ] and then there's some kind of
mitosis and meiosis mitochondria that's
exactly that's actually it's the food
for your cells you stopped producing it
over time
when you get older and this helps
basically plankton a lot of people use
it in their not using it as a treatment
in rehab
it's like anti-aging that's right yep
that's right
cuz I don't want to do that I already
like was born looking like I had Botox
and plastic surgery so I have to watch
it you know I have oily skin so like my
dad it's fantastic that's why you look
so good thank you so I'm always
slathering myself with oil you casually
mentioned this guy I'm having sex with
yeah this is not a boyfriend started
dating my vet
you got a fuck-boy you start dating your
vet I'm not surprised at all we gotta
talk about animals yes up with horse
therapy oh dude horse therapy is the
best I cannot believe I haven't dragged
you in Luck's out there cuz you guys are
gonna have horses at some point its
ambitious we're gonna need to work up to
that for quite some time
yeah like horses are expensive they're
involved right like can I just say
something the camera please put on Steve
from here you look like you have a giant
brown mullet because of the background
it looks like your hair so a coin
therapy which sounds very like rich to
say I don't I don't I don't you saddles
I don't use bits we don't use any force
it's something what I do is called
Liberty training it's just you and the
horse you don't wash the horse you know
only in the summertime you can rinse it
off but horses actually don't need to be
washed that much I don't braid its hair
I don't force it to jump or do anything
growing up I grew up in an alcoholic
home don't be jealous and there was so
much irresponsible communication in my
home it was a lot of people pretending
they were fine when they really weren't
fine a lot of unrecovered allanon's
right a lot of codependence it's a lot
of pretending everything is fine when
your mom is stumbling down the stairs in
front of all the neighbors and we it's a
lot of irresponsible communication no
one ever said I'm upset with you and
here's why it was a lot of like no I
think when everyone's clearly consumed
with rage and so I just was very
confused as a child as a result and very
untrusting of people's what anyone said
when someone said you want to hang out
and like do you really want is that you
trying to you know I like you but do you
are you just trying to [ __ ] with me
because if you like me that means you're
gonna yell at me tomorrow like I just
had very
dyslexic emotional dyslexia and turns of
what was up what was down I moved to
Roanoke Virginia when I was like 12 to
live with my aunts they had horses I
spent most of my time with them and I
was so relieved by how clear the
communication is in the animal world
like there's no passive aggressive
manipulative they've run off energy they
only pick up on your energy that's right
100% and they will let you know where
you stand they're not worried about you
hurting their feelings they're not
worried about hurting your feelings the
lead mayor is in charge and the way that
she behaves is to claim space to be in
charge to be proud and respect herself
and the more she does so the more
everyone respects her whereas I was
taught if you stand up for yourself
you're gonna hurt people's feelings
you're gonna make people angry you're
gonna upset a narcissist right like
horse therapy you're saying that your
horse therapist basically and when I
first started doing it because I grew up
riding horses the wrong way horses were
property they were for your results only
you rid them you broke them I mean they
literally call it breaking and winking
in spirit you break its spirit that's
exactly it's right now my spirit was
very broken when I first started working
with horses I had no idea to say how to
stand up for myself I had no idea how to
respect myself I thought that the nicer
I was to something the more it would
like me which is not the case it comes
off desperate and unctuous its need
energy to me that's made of Wendy it's
slightly different because dogs do their
work they're rewarded can be food and
affection
whereas horses real reward is serenity
yes you can give him carrots and [ __ ]
like that just that just makes a [ __ ]
up diluted relationship but they can get
grass whenever they want they can get
food whenever they want they graze right
and their prey animals so they are
clairvoyant and super hyper vigilant
sensitive whereas dogs are predators and
they don't have to think the same way
they don't have to be as in tune to your
energy are you do know we're talking
about you my sponsor is kind of like a
horse whisperer cool and so I went with
him one time he's like here grab the
reins and I did it and like the thing
was like but he's like dude tells me a
lot about you you know
like and so he kind of like told me a
couple things to do and it started
moving with me and he was weird
what do you think were you trying to
control it I was scared you know so I
had like a nervous energy so when you're
scared the horse knows a horse can see
that a mountain lion is hungry there
their job is to feel fear so they feel
your fear a horse would never think this
guy's scared of me or what they don't
think that way so it's like oh there
must be a low amount lying around so any
kind of fear they are gonna assume
there's a predator close by but also to
them they don't have insecurity they
don't have [ __ ] like that so insecurity
the need for a photo the need to pet it
whatever it is they just interpret as
fear all that [ __ ] is just fear to them
there's fear or there's no fear there's
serenity or there's fear and when
there's fear they just want to get the
[ __ ] out of there part of my admission
work with my horse now was just standing
in a pen with him a big pen so that he
could go away when my energy was
repellent and just seeing if he wanted
to be near me just seeing if my energy
was repellent or conducive to serenity
and he'd come over and I go oh my god he
came over oh my god he's coming hear me
he's coming near me I hope he doesn't go
anywhere and as soon as I went I hope he
doesn't go anywhere
what doesn't leave he would leave
because he was like what is this [ __ ]
you know and it's just and I would stand
there for an hour and I go I hope he
comes over I hope he comes over and he
wouldn't come over because who the [ __ ]
wants to be around that energy and then
as soon as I was like you know what he's
never to come over I guess I should just
coming over it's you know so as soon as
I surrender to it and have no need for
results because that's a thing as we go
through life and we want so much
remember and we want them to like us we
want feedback we want them to love us
and it's all the irony is what we chase
we chase away yeah he really taught me
that so did you do that with your vet
[Laughter]
some Jedi Mind Tricks checks he it's
interesting I had a dog who got really
really sick I don't have to tell you
it's just the most old age
he's yes he's older and bigger and he
had some autoimmune thing and nobody
could figure out what it was and he's on
these pills and these pills and he can't
walk and I mean he's like the love of my
life and actually only like six so it
was like too soon so I'm like in a fetal
position yeah I mean like in fetal
position and then some dot look like I
Oh everyone's doing the best they can
but there's a reason they call it a
practice doctor practice veterinary
practice they're practicing they're
doing as much as they can with the
information they have so I go to three
different hospitals it's three different
diagnoses I'm like totally freaked out
you know you write you pay five hundred
dollars to three people and you still
don't have an answer and I put him on
these steroids that was just making it
so he couldn't pee and he couldn't walk
it was just a nightmare and then I took
it to him and he solved it right away so
that was hot I know and then I was
constantly abusing my power as someone
on television by like texting him all
day all night like with questions and
the quarantine happened and the texting
just hurt and then it just kind of it
sounds like a little bit like a
boyfriend
[Music]
such a scumbag yeah I think for me I
know myself and I know that when that
label comes up the same with the I love
you thing it's not that I am disgusting
and I am repelled by anyone who loves me
like that I don't want to be a part of a
club that would have the claustrophobia
feeling oh yes you're interested in me
now you mimic I feel sick
it's more than like I I start to put way
too much pressure and I start and I
think this is part of my programming of
like husband husband husband husband
easy a husband like I froze my eggs like
four five years ago that's the way to
beat the clock I think so because before
that whether it's biological whether
it's social construction whatever it is
whether it's the princess complex of the
Disney movies or the [ __ ] Katherine
Heigl movies I don't know what it was
but there was a we're on a date and if
you order a beer oh he's an order beer
so what for her the kid which he's just
gonna [ __ ] drink it's everything
turned into that which is not fair it's
putting too much pressure on you you
know and I would put every decision
under a microscope and turn it into well
when we're married you're gonna act
instead of just letting someone be who
they are playing detective 24/7 24/7 and
like and I I know that about myself I'm
working on it in my recovery but this
sort of perfection I need in order to
feel safe I can I can see to where what
you described from the horses applies to
this the only reason I could be in a
relationship at all is because my horse
taught me to not mother martyr
micromanage and not try to force
something relationships always have to
be 50/50 and the more I try to fix his
hair or you know change his you know
saddle pad the more he's just like are
you doing right are you you know and it
takes someone something nonverbal
because he can't go like that what are
you doing that I'm like why did you talk
to me like that and now we're fighting
about fighting and I think they'd
philosophical it's like boyfriend what
do you mean like I don't need a
boyfriend I'm perfectly fine on my own
and then by the virtue of having that
position then you're more it's I just
don't want to put pressure on anyone yes
I learned this from working with horses
and animals is that pressure is just the
worst thing that you can do to pollute a
situation you know no one does well in
depression no one wants to be under
pressure I don't wanna meet someone then
then be like she a wife or not
I'm gonna do some very not wife [ __ ]
every now and then and I don't want to
be like what give myself a pat on the
back for making the logo for the
thumbnail out of horses yeah that made
me I was by the way hug over that day we
I didn't end up finishing this and then
he brought me IVs that's like illegal I
think so broke a lot of hip or laws for
me some Michael Jackson doctor
um and but yes my horse has taught me
that you just can't have expectation
when someone you have to let them be
free and that's what we don't do with
horses that's why we break them we want
them to do exactly what we want but
that's not I love you isn't I needed a
shape shift and the person that makes me
feel comfortable and safe so that I love
you I love you as I love you even when I
feel abandoned cuz that's my problem
that's not your problem if I feel
abandoned that's I'm 37 years old
and as my therapist so definitely put
adults can't be abandoned they have cars
you know if I'm feeling unsafe that
might be my problem that might not be
your problem so but I think that when
like boyfriend comes up or whatever it
turns a little bit into like but you're
my boyfriend you can't act like this and
I just offered you oh yes I know myself
and I just don't want to do that the
same we would love I'm like let's just
not say I love you for a second like
because then it's like but you love me
how are you but you really [ __ ] I'm
deep in the thick of the jungle yeah but
somebody before like so like ten years
ago would you want to hear somebody say
I love you oh yeah yeah and then
whenever you're the complete opposite
yes I love you was like okay it was this
false sense of security I used to be all
about false sense of security I used to
be all about words all about empty
gestures and promises and stuff like
that now I'm just like let's not let's
just [ __ ] kick it and not force it
but is that the complete opposite of it
you know what I mean is maybe maybe
maybe is that as unhealthy as it was the
polar on that polar spectrum like it
could be I think that it just your
intentions are what I'm learning in
program or all that matters right I can
drive you to the airport if I truly just
want to drive you to the airport no
strings attached if I'm driving you to
the airport because I feel guilty I feel
bad I don't want you to not be mad at me
or like oh he [ __ ] did that one thing
this time for me now I'm gonna do this
thing and we're just in a codependent
[ __ ] show yeah so it's like if my
motives really are I just don't want to
put pressure on this and I respect you
so much and I just want to slowly ease
into it so none of my character defects
just kind of come out full force like I
just I need to go slower as I used to go
addictively fast I mean I wrote my book
about being a love addict where
like was getting in car accidents to
like get to someone's hat you know I
just I know my hippocampus well and I
just want to protect everyone from it
what's your book it's called I'm fine
and otherwise it's about codependence
and addiction and eating disorders so
it's a hoot when did that came in I want
to say two years ago cool yeah it came
out the day of the Vegas shooting I'm
the real victim here let me let me ask
you this do you sell them from your own
website do you have an online storage
it's you're such a [ __ ] badass with
all this stuff I don't know I'm sure
Scott is your guy really that's your
online you should be doing it yourself
and on top of that no I mean like don't
outsource it yeah because there's value
in doing it in your own ecosystem
because make it all the money weight
window when you outsource your merch
operation then you got everybody else
collecting your [ __ ] emails all your
data and that's like so bad do you know
how much value there isn't an email so
all these companies and are you tax up I
just signed up for gonna be on the
waiting list or I'm on the waiting list
it's [ __ ] killing me there okay you
want it okay great yeah okay good yeah
but yeah here's what I do with that with
the books I oughta grab every copy if
you buy my book from my website
it comes personally signed that's [ __ ]
awesome and that way it's like a
paperback book but like you know it's
it's worth more and then I would say for
all of you listening
I would harass Steve to do a zoom with
all your fans I did one like three weeks
ago it was it was about being awesome so
you might get some help because you can
get like a whatever hundred dollars for
a membership where you can do a thousand
people at once
oh [ __ ] on zoom and I was there for four
hours so over the four hours like six
thousand people were able to get in they
would come and they would go you know
some people stay for the whole four
hours which was so sweet but I was able
to like talk to I just like hanging like
I I just did a
show me your dog or your cat or your pet
and like what there who would voice them
in a movie and I asked like one other
question like what's a special talent
you do you know just so that we could
like talk to everybody and then you
record it and then we cut together all
these like videos of everybody like
showing their dog it was just like at a
time where we can't really connect it's
like a virtual meet-and-greet because
they can get a recording of it of you
and them talking yeah you know pay to be
a part no no no you just send the zoo if
it's 11 you send the zoom link to either
your community or post it on Twitter or
wherever like 10 minutes before great
let me ask you this there's there's this
this company called Architectural Digest
and they've got a YouTube channel and
this is like the new era of MTV Cribs
yes
yeah and they like would you do that yes
I would do it I'm just getting some
stuff changed my house is basically just
a bunch of horse posters right now and
I'm sure they were just like no so I'm
redoing some stuff and then I am gonna
do it yes so do you feel like that
invites like weird creepy fans like
showing up your house dude the weird
creepy fans at my house number one I'll
say and if you're not listening you're
not one of my creepy fans anymore I
guess I lost you but they're kind of hot
and yeah quite nice like I haven't had
any you know I've had some people that
are clearly like off their meds or see
things that aren't there or stuff like
that but you know I haven't had they're
very very they look they're hot they
look like Ashton Kutcher and you kind of
and I'm like I had a couple guys that
thought we had been emailing and I got
doxxed so some people were kind of just
showing up like leaving me bath bombs
and [ __ ] like I haven't had you know
especially now that I live sort of in
the wilderness I don't think I'm worth
trying to figure out you know three
gates two people but I feel really lucky
I've had some crazy experiences I've had
people like snap during shows Kevin
Christie once said and this is I think a
while back before I was known really for
anything maybe after my first special
when I was preparing for my second
special Kevin Christie 400 opens for me
whenever we would go down to
the Comedy Store in La Jolla and
whenever he tours with me it always ends
up happening I don't always know about
it because security takes him out but
you'll see it in that smaller venue and
he said in about like 40 minutes into
every show one man snaps one man either
turns you into his ex-wife or the girl
he couldn't get in high school he's in
the audience it's not always so for
example there was a I was doing this
joke it's so dumb to think about now but
I was doing a joke about how every man
somewhere in their house or apartment
has a jar full of coins
it's got like some random like fortunes
in it it's like a ring and like that's
just you take everything out of your
pocket separated right OCD like if any
other nation's currency have to be able
to pour it into the [ __ ] like
Canadian quarter like landing in the
jungle dump the whole thing out okay
can't have any [ __ ] errors and you do
that how often every guy's got that
right
so it always ends up that joke always
kills cuz it's just one of those
observation that's just like kind of
like everyone gets right away and there
was this guy that I had actually gotten
into the show I used to do this thing
where I would like right before the show
save for seeds if you send me an email
give you free seats or whatever tell me
your story and why you can't get tickets
and I'll get you tickets so this guy
writes in he's like thank you so much
I'm so grateful duh there's something
that happens though I've noticed when
you're nice to a fan they come at you
like oh my god I'm such a big fan you're
probably not even checking this I love
you so much and then you respond and
then all of a sudden they lose respect
for you and then it turns into hey I'm
running late can you save me a parking
spot really good what how did I go from
your hero to
we're no good goes unpunished yeah
unbelievable like hey where is it again
thank you come on um so a guy that I'd
gotten in because he was a vet or some
the vets I thought but a vet vet served
this country and he's in like the third
row or something and he he's dying
laughing he said the night of his life
he's having so much fun everyone's doing
great and I do the same why does every
guy somewhere in his house or apartment
have a jar full of coins and he just
went that's so we can pay for your [ __ ]
like something snapped in him bringing
up money or something or I his mother
something and so 40 minutes into oh and
then we had to remove him and you know
that louia Comedy Store has like one
side that's glass and he spent the whole
rest of the show staring at me because
he's talking about performing in a
comedy club yeah how you know this was
eight years ago I've started booking
some dates I mean for August Wow and
then here we are heads into the second
wave it's crazy yeah I don't know enough
about it but my guess is the I mean I
don't know do you think I've got some
dates like my next July supposed to be
July 17th Wow I think I have a casino in
Oklahoma it's a brick town brick town
comedy club
I talked to Brad Williams he went out
there at a great time I mean already
been out there but do the Germans just
miss him I don't know I'm less afraid
I'm less afraid in the comedy club then
the [ __ ] airplane to get there
Oklahoma you could drive yeah then the
weekend after Oklahoma is supposed to be
Rochester New York and that's when I
rescheduled it was already Rochelle in
the New Rochelle
I had the Carl's comedy at the Carlson
and we had this [ __ ] thing sold out
for like ages ago and we just moved it
over so it's ostensibly still satola
sold out I just
so weird going back on tours just like
even eating at a restaurant like I don't
know maybe it's like PTSD but I don't
yeah I think there's a lot of that
residual just you know we're all trying
emotionally traumatized and it's and
scared right there was like the this
whole quarantine lockdown and then there
was like super quarantine fatigue people
[ __ ] over it and then there was like
take to the streets and and like you
know let's do the Million Man March yeah
whatever happened to the pandemic and
then now we're going into the second
wave it's like ah I mean it's I think
there's two questions not only when can
we start back but when will the rooms be
conducive to comedy you know I hate to
go through all my jokes I was looking to
him the other day and I was like [ __ ]
like none of this works I don't want to
do an hour where I'm like well you know
pretty covin oh you know before the
invisible murderer came like I was
literally closing on a joke that was
about how as a woman when you shake a
man's hand they always give feedback on
how strong your handshake is or
something that's like something like
that's not what the jokes about why are
you guys shaking hands like it's like
shaking hands is over you know so I now
don't know how I even rework the joke to
make it happen Jim Jeffrey specials
coming out soon he's a good friend and I
hope he's not mad that I divulges but he
has this whole bit on like germophobes
and how like ridiculous they shot it
like a year ago yeah in the van coming
up awesome he's a gym is one of my
favorites the best yeah true i
absolutely [ __ ] love him so it's also
like not only that also I don't want to
do shows where I'm only talking about
kovat I think people want to escape sure
this can't you Bick what is you know
news I don't want to do comedy for
people in masks I just is not fair to
them you know so but it's also we're
very privileged that our parents and
grandparents don't live with us you know
a lot of people go home to live with
their grandparents you know so it's like
are we contributing to that in any way
you know it's just it's a it's I feel
like a day-by-day thing I mean I
remember when we were canceling
shows I cancel Detroit at 4 o'clock the
show is at 7:30 I mean that's how crazy
it was that's how and then I flew to
Houston and then that they declared a
state of emergency I had to cancel that
night I mean it was just has all been
changing by the day and if we go back to
that changing by the day thing it's just
gonna get so stressful yeah you know
it's been nice to get a break from
comedy but like the original observation
that I had where it's like wow this book
and guests and the podcast is getting so
stressful you know that's one thing
about the the grind of being on a comedy
tour is that yeah it's a [ __ ] grind
it's Groundhog Day it's it's no way to
live you know in a [ __ ] hotel room on
an airplane in a [ __ ] radio stations
like whatever that whole repeat so but
at least there's no variables that you
can't control how I'm sorry I want to go
back to this what is the problem with
asking people to be on your broadcast
it's that it's it's just that I feel
like I want to have like such like
impressive like you know high-caliber
guests where people are gonna think wow
I can't believe steve-o got that person
and you know don't you want them to go
wow that was an amazing interview yes
yeah and I think that that's just like I
think I'm just like it's gonna sound
douchey to say but I'm just like you
know a victim of my own ambition yeah
yeah no I got it perfectionism yeah like
I want to do so well I strive so hard to
do well and to be impressive
yeah and it's just like every week and
it's just I feel like I'm running and
there's an avalanche chasing me and it's
just I've gotta like keep getting a
guest before like I get buried and I
also think like I think maybe you forget
sometimes and please tell me if I'm are
oh you're famous I have a profile people
love you like I I would like to see an
episode like of you and your therapist
she's gonna mean you're so introspective
you're so surprising like you're so
clear like you know I I would like to
see you and Lux do enough I think
try to come today oh I asked her to come
she said
he asked Whitney about how she's
welcoming dick pics I refuse to do this
like dick pics traumatize me they're
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah and I love them and there should be
like a dating app where instead of faces
it's like dicks and [ __ ] why are we
pretending the dick pics like like fine
they are were they also I am obsessed
with the backgrounds of dick pics
because there's always like a plate of
wings there's always such a story in the
background that I'd like to piece
together I'm like are those are those
Christmas sheets like it's in June homey
so I just love I love to see the inside
of people's bathrooms they know this
about me I'm kind of a pervert about
seeing just like your towels and your
Irish spring bar of soap like suck like
I just I love that okay what percentage
of the dick pics have like a tummy
covered in [ __ ] like a post load you
don't I don't get a ton of post load
ones I send a lot of them yeah you want
to go pre
you don't need like a shrunken dick
after you're not my god just seeing all
the things I I'm big on finding I think
people are so bullying men right now a
man or like guys have insecurities to
the seeing guys place their penis the
way they put their hand around it to
make it look bigger and the shaving it
breaks my heart I mean it is really just
so sweet
wait here's one I mean this one is a
look oh there's a calm one that's a come
one wow that's a pretty large penis
beginning put it over black cuz he
wanted to come to pop right I appreciate
your thinking so they're DMing you and
your screen grabbing it yeah i screen
grab him and send him Joe rogue it's a
vase they know they're usually in
grabbed and they're probably like oh oh
here's some good ones see this is this
is just like a shame
the full shaving he put a flash on
that's a real mushroom poll got new
looks like a Russian nesting doll it's
very sad let's encourage everybody to
not only send you dick pics but to make
sure that they're following you at a
great follow
it's just Whitney Cummings videos of
steve-o on my youtube you're welcome
we got your YouTube we got your
Instagram we got your Twitter your
Facebook you gotta say all this I mean
the liking and subscribe I just I'm so
bad at promoting myself I haven't done
tik-tok yet yes I'm on tick-tock oh my
god I've gotta do this look it's so dude
you're [ __ ] designed for tick-tock
that's yeah that's what David Ober was
built for you I know
alright did Paul we're gonna have to
start breaking up our archival content
and it's untick dogs I put some standup
clips on there I didn't let's be honest
someone cut them up put them on there
got like 7 million views on there don't
know no idea I enjoy watching it too oh
look this is my favorite of all time
it's a guy and then there's a girl
behind him oh wow phlex imagine telling
this girl like no your heads going down
mark the down mark just help put your
head down a little more it's a weird
position I hope she's crying behind him
yeah sign up on Sorenson you welcome
dick pics on all platforms I just you
know a 189 text text pic crop your head
out because I don't trust myself and
your your your text text number is in
your profile and your bio on Instagram
and we're gonna get Steve a text soon
it's a great way to take because here's
the thing
half of our posts in the main feed of
Instagram aren't getting in the right
algorithm yes okay you're getting you
got it I'm sold on the community thing
it's the tic-tock that I'm still resist
but I think your your fans need to
understand
it's not we're not trying to mine your
data the reason we're doing this is it
doesn't take your data we will know
we're able to then mark it to you
specifically just people in Orlando for
the Orlando show just people in New
Rochelle New York for you so I'm not
blasting everybody I'm not fasting Texas
with my Florida dates this is a way to
just text you directly to be less
annoying believe it or not ya know I'm
sold on community and I I gotta do this
this thing you have to go I know yeah I
love you thanks for having me I'm just
trying to find more dicks for you we
should come up with a better end than
that I was hungover and puking on yeah I
said it was terrible dry cough how about
that huh I really think that was a
special episode and I really think that
I'm growing as a podcaster
yeah I'm feel free to tell me I'm not
and I'll probably see it because I have
been checking out comments and even
though when I leave a comment it says
steve-o's Wild Ride podcast that comment
is totally coming from me try not to be
mean though because it does hurt my
feelings in any case I don't know um
thanks again to Whitney Cummings what I
want to say this straight team you guys
are the best when we do this trick where
everybody takes a screenshot of the
podcast and then they put it out on
their social media and wherever I see it
Instagram and Twitter are really the
only one places I'm going to see it but
whenever I see it I'd like it and I'm
always so grateful and not kidding about
the whoop strap dude like again get it
on get on over to whoop calm and use the
promo code steve-o 15% off like I
think it's very very beneficial but yeah
thank you as always I love you guys